allez on joue maintenant pour un dernier
truc une promo dans la rue de france
inter sur un caddie scooter avec megafon
regarder je me tue à non je vous jure
que je mette ça va 2 alors isabelle
aller avoue je suis sidéré par là bas
vous a conduit ici rassure mais mme
harel était le slogan de rtl en 91 vache
s'est bien préparée avec quatre choix
multiples noms n'a pas mais parce qu'il
s'inquiétait pas encore dépassé nagui si
la guinée sur france inter à
l'éventuelle donc être très dur c'est
sûr qu'il y en a un par an il y en a
deux parents allait jouer aux
différentes sans rtl l'information au
capital est pas le meilleur est écouté
et isabelle morini-bosc bien sûr sur rtl
tous les jours à 9h15 mais pour
l'instant isabelle rejoignez votre
caddie regarder france inter pour y
aller regarder les gens vous attendent
dans la rue oui et je fais quoi
bah vous allez voir on va tomber 10 a
été sacké sais pas isa vous et le
toulouse est toujours pas le permis non
mais non merci pas sûrs et a l'air
simple je vous rappelle que je suis
tombé de vélo à la règle je me suis fait
une double fracture du bassin mais la
place est impossible à l'ag vous dire
normalement cela va avec le pistolet de
bernard valette avec ça après tout faire
pour tourner vers les halles et la vie
nomade jamais nous attend sur ma maison
j'ai pris de la vitesse voilà baby loup
les ans on rit on parle un peu plus de
ça on a envie d'y aller ça fait rien
attention